[Orientalische Musik]
SALLY: Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute mit...
SAMIRA: Samira.
SALLY: [Lacht] Wir haben uns gedacht,
dass wir zum Abschluss der Ramadanreihe,
denn jetzt ist ja der Fastenmonat vorbei, noch ein Rezept machen.
Die letzten Jahre war es immer so, dass Zuschauer immer gesagt haben:
„Mach du mal eine Ramadantorte.“
Aber eigentlich passt eine Torte auch nicht so richtig zum Ramadan,
denn es wird nicht so gefeiert,
wie man es vielleicht von Weihnachten kennt.
Also zumindest war es bei uns so,
dass wenn der Fastenmonat vorbei war,
man drei Tage lang ein Fest hatte.
Da ist es dann so, man besucht die Älteren,
also die Familienmitglieder: Oma, Opa, Tanten, Onkels.
Da wir eine große Familie haben,
war es bei uns eben immer ein sehr großer Familienbesuch.
Dann kann es schon sein, dass man am Tag bei etwa 10 Familien war.
Da isst man nicht immer ein Stück Torte.
Deswegen gibt es auch traditionell immer
kleinere Ramadandesserts oder kleines Gebäck,
dass man überall ein bisschen was zum Tee dazu essen kann.
Da aber dieses Jahr die Umstände wie im letzten Jahr
ganz anders sind, finde ich, sollten wir etwas zubereiten,
was man machen kann.
Es werden ja keine Familienbesuche durchgeführt
und man verbringt dann doch eher zu Hause mit der eigenen Familie.
Aber trotzdem, finde ich, könnt ihr den anderen Familien, Nachbarn
und Freunden zeigen, dass ihr an sie denkt.
Deswegen haben wir uns gedacht, machen wir die Kekse.
Du hast ja auch schon welche mit Oma gebacken, gell?
SAMIRA: Ja.
SALLY: Was habt ihr da gemacht?
SAMIRA: Wir haben einfach Butter, Puderzucker, Öl, ...
SALLY: Nicht das Rezept aufsagen. Wie heißen die?
SAMIRA: Ehm...
SALLY: Un Kurabiyesi.
SAMIRA: Ja. Mehlkekse.
SALLY: Meine Mama mag nämlich Kekse ganz arg, die ganz mürbe sind.
Als wir mit Josh und Sarah in der Türkei,
haben wir sie auch die Kekse probieren lassen.
Murat mag sie nicht so gern, weil sie eben staubig sind,
aber ich und Sarah und, ich glaube, Josh, du auch?
Okay, du mochtest sie auch nicht so, aber Sarah und ich waren...
Es trifft nicht so ganz den deutschen Geschmack, muss man sagen.
Heute haben wir uns gedacht, machen wir ein schnelles Keksrezept.
„Pratik Kurabiye Tarifi“ heißt es auf Türkisch.
Wir machen jetzt einen Basisteig,
der anders ist als ein normaler Mürbeteig:
Dieser wird einfach direkt weiterverarbeitet.
Also man muss echt nicht lange warten, bereitet den Teig einfach zu
und daraus machen wir dann verschiedene Variationen.
Hier ist jetzt einmal der Basisteig,
also der Grundteig für alle Variationen.
Dafür verwenden wir 250 g weiche Butter, 150 g Puderzucker,
etwas Salz, 500 g Mehl, 1 Päckchen Backpulver – das sind 3 TL -,
etwas Wasser und 2 Eigelb.
Im Prinzip kann die Samira jetzt einfach den Teig zubereiten.
Es kommen nämlich alle Zutaten in eine Rührschüssel.
Beim Wasser achtet ihr einfach darauf:
Das Wasser noch nicht dazu geben. Das kommt zum Schluss,
denn jetzt werden alle Zutaten verrührt, okay?
Du kannst sie alle hineingeben.
SAMIRA: Erstmal die Butter.
SALLY: Sie sollte weich sein.
SAMIRA: Jetzt kommt der Puderzucker.
SALLY: Da nehmen wir jetzt auch Puderzucker und keinen normalen,
denn dieser ist ganz fein und löst sich praktisch direkt im Teig auf.
Deswegen müssen wir ihn auch nicht warten lassen.
SAMIRA: 1 Prise?
SALLY: Genau, 1 Prise Salz. Perfekt!
Mehl – da geht auch Dinkelmehl 630 oder ganz normales Weizenmehl.
SAMIRA: Puderzucker.
SALLY: Backpulver.
SAMIRA: Oh. [Sally schmunzelt]
SALLY: Die heißen ja auch „Puf Kurabiye“,
weil sie so puf puf aufgehen.
[Musik]
Mein Kind! Sie kratz aus; sie kratzt das Eigelb aus. Ich bin so stolz!
Jetzt wird der Teig verknetet.
Ihr könnt es auch mit dem Handrührgerät machen.
Ich gebe einfach nach und nach Wasser dazu, so viel wie nötig;
also dass einfach ein schöner weicher Teig entsteht.
Es kommt darauf an, wie groß die Eigelbe sind,
aber im Normalfall 1-3 EL.
Soll ich es runterklappen? [Samira bejaht]
Die Kekse oder Keksteig geht auch sehr schnell,
vor allem, wenn ihr die Kenwood mit der Waage habt.
Einfach alles direkt hineinwiegen.
Dann hat man echt gar keine Arbeit damit.
Ich stelle sie kurz ein. Dann kommt noch der Deckel darauf.
SAMIRA: Schade.
SALLY: Du darfst jetzt unten auf den Knopf drücken.
[Musik]
Wir haben jetzt hier den fertigen Teig.
Der sieht auch wunderbar aus, also ein richtig schöner, weicher Teig.
Schau! Schön, gell?
Der schmeckt jetzt erst einmal nur nach Butter und Zucker.
Daraus machen wir jetzt einmal zwei Kekse
und später kommen noch einmal zwei andere Variationen.
Wir machen jetzt einmal Haselnuss- und Schokokekse.
Ich dachte nämlich, du willst mit Schokolade anfangen.
Für die Haselnusskekse nehmen wir etwas Zimt, Vanilleextrakt,
1 Eiweiß und geröstete, gehackte Haselnüsse.
Für die Schokoladenkekse nehmen wir
Kakao, etwas Wasser, Tonka Wonka, Eiweiß und Schokoladenstreusel.
Also wir machen es jetzt so: Ich nehme jetzt hier den Teig heraus.
Du kannst ihn einmal zu einer Kugel formen,
damit wir ihn halbieren können.
Den gleichen Teig mache ich gleich noch einmal im Anschluss,
dass wir einfach schön vier Sorten haben.
In meinem Blog und in meiner App gebe ich es euch aber als
vier Einzelrezepte an. Dann wisst ihr, wieviel Gramm wovon.
Aber wenn ihr, wie gesagt, auch vier Variationen machen wollt,
macht einfach die doppelte Menge an Teig,
viertelt ihn und dann könnt ihr eben die Zusätze mit dazu geben.
Sehr schön. Jetzt halbieren.
SAMIRA: Nochmal?
SALLY: Reicht; halbieren.
Den gebe ich wieder hier zurück.
Du kannst jetzt hier nämlich Vanilleextrakt und Zimt einkneten.
Dafür brauchen wir jetzt keine Maschine mehr.
SAMIRA: Wieviel?
SALLY: Einfach so 1/2 TL, so ein bisschen.
SAMIRA: Nicht wie die Ela einen Tropfen.
SALLY: Nicht wie Ela. [Lacht]
Und dann übertreibt sie es, gell? [Samira stimmt zu]
Jetzt Zimt noch mit hinein.
SAMIRA: Entweder macht sie richtig wenig oder ganz viel.
SALLY: Genau. Jetzt so ein bisschen mit Hand.
In den Schokoteig kommt jetzt Kakao, etwas Wasser
und, weil es geschmacklich gut passt, Tonka Wonka
oder ein bisschen Tonkabohne hineinreiben.
[Musik]
Hier kurz das Eiweiß ein bisschen verrühren.
Jetzt könnt ihr einen kleinen Eisportionierer nehmen.
Damit kannst du das jetzt nämlich portionieren.
Guck, immer so glatt und dann Kugeln formen.
Dann hat man immer eine gleiche Portion, ja? [Samira bejaht]
Genau, dann sind sie schön gleichgroß.
Dann nehmt ihr diese Kugel,
taucht sie zuerst mit der Oberfläche in Eiweiß
und dann in die Haselnüsse.
Dann eventuell noch ein bisschen nachformen.
[Musik]
Dann hole ich schon einmal das zweite Blech.
Jetzt haben wir schon einmal ein Blech fertig.
Seht ihr? Das geht ruckzuck.
Beim zweiten Blech nehmen wir die Schokostreusel, das Eiweiß.
Das Eiweiß nehmen wir auch gleich weiter.
Das benutzen wir gleich mit.
Jetzt noch einmal die Kugeln portionieren.
[Musik]
SAMIRA: Mama? Sollen wir ganz ummanteln?
SALLY: Okay, komm! Die Schokokekse ummanteln wir ganz.
Die kannst du auch wahrscheinlich... Guck mal, einfach so.
So ein bisschen darin hüpfen lassen.
SAMIRA: [Lacht] Ja.
SALLY: Weil sonst hast du alles in den Fingern.
Oh, das ist wie eine Trüffelpraline. Lecker!
SAMIRA: Was ist Trüffel?
SALLY: So eine Praline, die man aus Schokolade und Sahne macht.
SAMIRA: Ach so. Ich habe gedacht, wie Trüffel, der Pilz.
SALLY: Super. Also diese jetzt auch portionieren. Ups.
Eine Kugel formen, in Eiweiß tauchen und dann in Schokoraspeln wälzen.
[Musik]
Jetzt haben wir hier die zwei Bleche schon fertig.
Komm, die können wir in den Backofen stellen.
Am besten beide gleichzeitig bei Heißluft.
In der Zeit - wir haben auch schon einmal den zweiten Teig gemacht -
zeigen wir euch noch zwei Variationen.
Deins jetzt weiter oben.
Dann können sie bei Heißluft nämlich gleichzeitig backen. Sehr gut!
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Du darfst den Teig wieder halbieren.
Ich habe jetzt hier Pistazien. Die werden fein gemahlen.
[Musik]
Ihr habt bestimmt auch noch ein paar Datteln übrig.
Dann könnt ihr diese nämlich noch fein würfeln.
Ich nehme sie jetzt auch noch. Ich nehme natürlich entsteinte Datteln
oder ihr nehmt einfach den Stein heraus.
Die schneide ich in Würfel
und du kannst schon einmal die Hälfte des Teiges hier hineingeben.
SAMIRA: Okidoki. Das kommt jetzt rein? [Sally stimmt zu]
[Musik]
SALLY: Die Pistazien noch dazu.
Jetzt die Pistazien und Datteln kurz einkneten.
[Musik]
SAMIRA: Ich habe für Oma ein Croissant gemacht.
SALLY: Ja?
SAMIRA: Ja. Das muss gebacken werden.
SALLY: Okay. Aber es kann sein, dass es da drauf verbrennt,
weil es so klein ist.
Guck mal, die Pistazienkekse machen wir jetzt ganz einfach:
Da nehmen wir jetzt nämlich den Eisportionierer
und setzen einfach solche Kugeln auf das Blech.
Die formen wir gar nicht rund, denn da ist es auch immer ganz schön,
wenn die oben ein bisschen aufplatzen
und so ein bisschen rissig aussehen.
SAMIRA: Platzkekse. [Schmunzelt]
SALLY: Ja, die platzen. Magst du das machen? [Samira stimmt zu]
Immer darauf achten, dass diese Eisoberfläche,
weil ich finde, das sieht aus wie eine Kugel Eis,
einfach oben ist.
Guck, so mit der glatten Seite auf das Blech und dann lösen.
SAMIRA: Pistazieneis.
SALLY: Ja, Pistazien-Datteleis.
SAMIRA: Das müssen wir mal machen.
SALLY: Mmh! Pistazien-Datteleis-Kekse.
Guck, so ein bisschen ankleben und dann lösen, ja? [Samira stimmt zu]
Ich kann in der Zwischenzeit den restlichen Teig zubereiten.
SAMIRA: Stopp! Kann ich ein ganz kleines bisschen haben?
Dann kann ich noch etwas formen.
SALLY: Da gebe ich noch ein bisschen Tahin dazu.
Das ist eine Sesampaste.
Ein bisschen Sesam. Die formen wir gleich noch einmal anders.
[Musik]
Bei der letzten Kekssorte, also den Sesamkeksen,
machen wir es auch wieder mit dem Eisportionierer.
So habt ihr auch den Vorteil,
dass alle Kekse gleichzeitig fertig sind,
denn sie haben alle die gleiche Größe
und ihr habt einfach nur eine Backofenheizart,
also 170°C Heißluft und eigentlich immer 20 Minuten.
Deswegen passt es perfekt.
Die portionieren wir jetzt so, formen sie rund.
Dann tauche ich die Unterseite in Sesam.
Jetzt wird der Keks mit einem Stempel,
ihr könnt auch eine Gabel nehmen,
aber ich nehme jetzt hier den Stempel.
Den tauche ich vorher in Mehl.
Dann wird er schön geprägt und sozusagen flachgedrückt.
Dadurch entsteht ein richtig schönes Muster.
[Musik]
Wir sind jetzt fertig, haben vier Bleche Kekse gebacken
und das ging wirklich sagenhaft schnell.
Es ist wirklich ein 5-Minuten-Keksteig.
Ich gebe euch, wie gesagt, im Blog die Rezepte einzeln an,
aber auch noch das Basisrezept.
Dann könnt ihr entscheiden, was und wie viele ihr davon machen möchtet
und natürlich auch gern Abwandlungen davon.
Okay Samira, welcher Keks spricht dich am meisten an?
SAMIRA: Schoko.
SALLY: Habe ich mir gedacht.
Mich spricht tatsächlich der Haselnusskeks an.
Komm, dann probieren wir einmal!
Probiere du deinen.
Mmh!
SAMIRA: Mmh!
SALLY: Gut? [Samira bejaht]
Eigentlich lässt man ja Kekse immer eine Nacht ruhen.
Die werden dann nämlich noch weicher,
aber die sind jetzt schon richtig gut mürbe.
Und was spricht mich noch an?
Also eigentlich alle, ich probiere noch den mit Sesam.
Mmh!
Auch sehr gut. Und diesen probiere ich gleich hinter der Kamera.
Ihr müsst mich ja nicht beim Essen sehen und dabei zugucken.
Was ich jetzt ganz schön finde:
Jetzt könnt ihr eure Kekse einzeln verpacken
oder auch direkt vermischen und dann schön verschenken.
An Oma würden wir es mit einem Glas verschenken,
mit einem kleinen Schild dran: „Bayramın mübarek olsun“
Also mit schönen Glückwünschen zum Ramadanfest.
Ihr könnt aber auch Muffinförmchen nehmen und sie da reinpacken
oder Papiertütchen oder kleine Folientütchen.
Ihr könnt sie einfach so schön verpacken und verschenken.
Vielleicht habt ihr auch noch andere Ideen,
wie man diesen Teig abwandeln kann,
eine Keksvariation, die euch am besten schmeckt.
Dann schreibt sie uns gern in die Kommentare.
Ich würde sagen, wir verpacken sie jetzt und verschenken sie, oder?
Dann darfst du zur Omi. Da wartet sie schon die ganze Zeit darauf.
Also viel Spaß beim Backen.
Hayırlı Ramazanlar. Ramazan bayramınız mübarek olsun.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Vor allem cool, dass wir fast kein Werkzeug gebraucht haben,
und so schnell!
SAMIRA: Aber die nehme ich mit.
SALLY: Okay. Und ich nehme diese mit.
[Musik]
[Orientalische Musik]